David good morning how you feeling after
that win I'm feeling great feeling
fantastic when does the pain start to
set in after a game Oh usually after you
know after the games but when we get a
victory it's not as best how would you
describe your running style if somebody
had never seen you run how would you
describe it uh I probably say little um
50 a little deceptively speed a little
of doing it you know doing at all what's
your official heightened wait official
height is 61 225 225 hard to put on
weight or keep off weight it is I'm a
little bit about my weight fluctuates a
little bit especially for the season but
I usually stay around the 225 area you
ever heard a defensive player kind of
winter grimace or cry out empty run into
him no it's easily a good run you know a
lot of guys starting to give me some
respect and done you know notice how
effective of a runner i am I remember
that Jerome Bettis said that he actually
heard a guy kind of the air went out of
him he could hear the air go out of a
defensive player who tried to tackle
Jerome Bettis you never had that happen
I've had to happen a few times but you
know Jerome the bus is a big hitter he's
definitely hard to take down biggest
college offer coming out of high school
was where northern iowa that was due
from Northern Iowa and Illinois State
how did that happen like when did you
become pro potential uh I think it's
just because I'm I'm from Iowa I played
football there and I wasn't the biggest
guy come now if I about 180 sighs and I
was about 61 and a lot of teeth you know
what i was talking on recruiting they
said they didn't know where they're
putting their in effect by running back
receiver or a DB or and so a lot of
teams were currently to place to be an
athlete to figure out where
haven't played you know the my college
career went on so a lot of teams kind of
overlooking that way and I felt like you
know your northern I was definitely my
best fit I'm just because of you know
how good they are and I think that's
when I started to realize that I had a
chance to play in the pros all right one
of my guys Seton has your draft profiles
it okay if we read it might have some
some negative stuff here coming out of
college but this is the official draft
profile of you are you ready for this
yeah all right seat and read it well
there's some positives in there there
should be of course of course smooth
pass-catcher out of the backfield a
mismatch for linebackers but some of the
weaknesses are kind of funny okay long
Strider I'm not really sure what that
means doesn't always look like he has
the foot quickness to burst through the
whole consistently oh boy Johnson lacks
the short area quickness to be a
consistent effective every-down running
back is that true David no no definitely
I was definitely good when I was gonna
give you know recruiting the pros and a
lot of teams were talk to me about that
stuff do you have a nickname no I do not
have a nickname I'll think about it last
night after talking to my Hasselbeck and
it's definitely tough for me to come up
with when I've been trying to you know I
tweeted out and if anyone has came up
with any good ones but it's tough
because my name is no comment and I just
can't you know fine order thinkable all
right were you called anything when
you're growing up like pookie or Ray Ray
uh no usually DJ um I mean in when I
first started playing a lot of my
teammates and Friends recology the road
runner going to be in 6a but but I
really don't have any good one okay I
got one for you I'm gonna call you dirt
as in pay dirt because you scored
touchdown see your dirt Johnson short
for Peter that sounds good i have to you
know tweeted out maybe into this what
all my fans and friends think about that
yeah
but yeah we were trying to come up with
a good nickname for you because you do
have a common name you're David Johnson
so I thought dirt not be good yeah seton
do you have one for David yeah i went
with um bull bull yeah ball like bowl
Johnson cuz he's got you know big body
and actually one of his strengths on
this draft profile was said looks good
on the hoof who looks good on this early
we don't Bowl there you go all right
mclovin do you have one for David yeah
it's like DJ but you put a the in front
of it that when you get in the end zone
you do a little scratching thing with
your hands like you're a DJ mixing oh I
wanted to I like it all right you could
be good though good one you could be DJ
p.m. because you play in the afternoon
or the evening instead of DJ am your DJ
p.m. and then you do some scratching in
there when you get to the end zone
Paulie I might have to drive it like
polygraph you have one for David well he
just called himself shifty in her shady
McCoy and shifty Johnson would be kind
of natural but he went to high school I
think Clinton Iowa and they were the
lumber came you said now here comes a
lumber king around the corner the lumber
come by just lumber lumber king or
lumber bringing the lumber what do you
think David we were actually we're in a
river came close i baseball team with
this number king o weekly are a triple-a
baseball oh okay alright so Fritzi do
you have one for david i think because
he's chiseled and he's something we can
all admire when he's carrying the ball
the david oh yes yes he could so he
strikes the pose of the david and when
he gets to the end zone then I'm sure
the Commission will throw a couple of
grand of a fine his way but if you can
get past that I think it's some we can
hang one don't know if I want it when
july some you were fine David last time
what you were fined by the NFL uh I've
never have not been fined by the NFL so
don't get you gotta get your name out
there look at Odell Beckham you know
you're getting fine he's making you know
he's got his brand he's got you know
everybody knows who is you got to take
your helmet off maybe a dye your hair a
little bit here I'm
come on David let's we got to get it we
gotta get a brand going I gotta get ya I
had to do something but I don't know I
don't know if I can take the front it'll
be tough well congrats so far and he's
dirt Johnson or you can call him the
David and another big night last night
David thanks for joining us and I'm sure
you're going to be anxious to run into
that Seattle defense right oh yeah there
exists is gonna be a good rivalry
between us do you hate him but again do
you hate cm no I respective I mean
they're a good decent especially good
team but you know and you know it's
always a big game when we play those
guys and dogs gonna be a physical game
so you know I got to try to hurry up and
get rejuvenated for that game you know
do what I can to help off again well
congrats not only this year but last
year as well thanks for joining us
thanks adam lanza david johnson the Dan
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience